Well guys, that's a wrap for the final CS:GO Major of the year,
and once again Astralis are on top of the Counter-Strike world.
They won on the back of dominating discipline, incredible teamplay
and, of course, individual brilliance.
Now, over the course of this Major, we saw two-and-a-half weeks of nearly non-stop CS action.
We felt chills down our spine watching some incredible plays
and of course we heard the crowd at SSE Arena in Wembley
make their voices heard cheering on hometown heroes
smooya and dephh.
There really were so many incredible plays from this Major
and we’ve distilled them all into one neat little package, just for you.
But only the best of the best.
Now let's get things started with the kind of plays that make you just wanna spam “VAC” in the chat.
Alright guys, those were some pretty incredible plays, borderline suspicious plays,
but it's not all about being flashy, oh no.
It's about getting the W,
and what better way than when you do it solo.
So with that in mind, here are the best clutches from this past Major.
OK, so it's one thing to clutch when your entire team is dead
and you basically have no choice.
It's another entirely to turn to your squad and say "hold my beer."
Here are the best Aces from London.
Guys, there were so many sick plays from this past Major, we couldn't put them all into neat little categories.
So here's a section we're calling, the best of the rest of nutty plays from the Major.
OK guys, that's it for the Best of the FACEIT London Major.
Now if you did enjoy this video, drop a like, drop a comment and subscribe to the channel.
That's what I call a "YouTube Ace."
And if you're still jonesin' for that Major content,
Well, in less than twenty four hours, we're dropping the best fails and funny moments from this past Major.
I'll see you then.